en este vídeo vamos a hablar sobre las
hojas de balance bancarias en un sistema
bancario de reservas fraccionarias ahora
no sólo los bancos tienen hojas de
balance todas las empresas tienen hojas
de balance ustedes mismos pueden tener
su hoja de balance individual es una
vista rápida de lo que se tiene en valor
y lo que le debes a otras personas ahora
las cosas que tienen valor si estamos
hablando de bancos las cosas de valor
que tienen los bancos se llaman activos
y eso podría ser efectivo que tienen los
bancos en sus bóvedas podrían ser las
propiedades que el banco posee y las
cosas que el banco le debe a otras
personas son pasivos pasivos y esto
podría ser dinero que el banco le debe a
otras personas alguna obligación futura
ahora hay este otro concepto que es el
capital cuando estamos hablando de una
empresa como un banco el capital es el
sobrante si toman sus activos y restan
sus pasivos el capital es el valor neto
que tanto del valor neto es propiedad de
los accionistas y para que esto sea
tangible pueden ver una analogía de la
vida cotidiana si piensan en su propia
hoja de balance digamos que el único
activo que tienen es un auto que vale 10
mil pesos 10 mil pesos y digamos que
sólo tienen un pasivo tuvieron que pedir
un préstamo de 8 mil pesos para comprar
ese auto de 10 mil pesos de modo que
esto es algo que le deben a alguien más
entonces este es su pasivo cuál sería su
capital aquí cuál sería el valor neto
bueno si poseen algo que vale 10 mil
pesos si todos sus activos son 10.000
pero deben 8000 cuánto es lo que queda
es igual a 2 mil pesos y este sería su
capital que muchas veces se le llama
valor neto entonces activos menos
pasivos
la capital o si suman los pasivos a los
dos lados podríamos decir que los
activos son iguales a los pasivos más el
capital y cuando ven hojas de balance es
común ver dos columnas del lado
izquierdo tenemos los activos y del lado
derecho tenemos los pasivos más el
capital
y la suma de estas columnas deben
resultar en la misma cantidad no importa
que tanto haya de activos los pasivos
más el capital debe sumar la misma
cantidad
entonces usemos ese antecedente para
comenzar un banco
digamos que inmediatamente compramos un
edificio y algunos equipos que valen un
millón de pesos para tener un lugar para
el banco de modo que inmediatamente
tenemos en los activos edificio más
equipo por un millón de pesos
ahora yo diría que cualquiera que fuera
nuestra cantidad de activos eso debe ser
igual a los pasivos más el capital
entonces en esta situación cuáles son
nuestros pasivos hasta ahora recuerden
que el balance nos da un panorama en
cualquier momento bueno hasta ahora no
le debo nada a nadie voy a suponer que
tenía ese millón de pesos no tuve que
pedir prestado a nadie para obtener ese
millón entonces tengo cero pesos en
pasivos y cuál sería mi capital pausa en
el vídeo y traten de pensar en esto
bueno los pasivos más el capital deben
sumar un millón si los pasivos son
iguales a cero entonces nuestro capital
es igual a un millón de pesos de modo
que si soy el dueño del banco esto me
indica que el valor de lo que poseo es
de un millón de pesos pero como sabemos
los bancos no existen solamente para
tener un edificio obtienen depósitos de
las personas y luego hacen préstamos a
otras personas entonces digamos que
alguien va caminando por la calle y ve
nuestro banco
oye ese parece un buen lugar para
depositar dinero parece un lugar seguro
tal vez se interesen en el entonces
vienen y depositan un millón de pesos en
efectivo
tienen una maleta con un millón de pesos
en efectivo así que como se verá
reflejado esto en la hoja de balance
bueno en realidad debería quedar
clasificado como reservas reservas que
se pueden ver como similares a las de la
reserva federal el efectivo que tienen a
la mano podría ser el dinero que está en
su bóveda podría ser una cuenta en el
banco central aunque ese es un poco más
sofisticado pero podemos visualizarlo
como su efectivo es una manera de
simplificarlo de modo que en esta
situación las reservas van a ser de un
millón de pesos de donde vino esto vino
de una maleta con efectivo que dio una
persona ahora qué pasa con el lado
derecho de esta hoja de balance no
simplemente nos dieron el dinero en el
futuro podrían retirar parte del dinero
o todo el dinero ahora en nuestros
pasivos tenemos depósitos a la vista
dejen escribirlo de esta manera
depósitos a la vista
por un millón de pesos este es un buen
momento para pausar el vídeo y entender
esto porque esto es esencial para
entender bancos es que si tenemos ese
efectivo pero está compensado por un
pasivo porque en algún momento en el
futuro tenemos que devolver ese millón
de pesos a la persona que hizo ese
depósito y pueden venir a pedirlo ahora
podrían decir está bien todo esto está
bien pero como voy a ganar dinero como
banco y la manera principal en que los
bancos ganan dinero es haciendo
préstamos pero como prestan el dinero si
todo esto es un depósito a la vista
bueno en un sistema de reserva
fraccionaria no tienen que tener todos
sus depósitos a la vista disponibles
como reservas en realidad pueden prestar
una buena parte de eso y está regulado
por las proporciones de reservas
requeridas entonces digamos que en el
país en el que estamos o en la
jurisdicción en la que estamos el
coeficiente de reservas requerido es del
10 por ciento de los depósitos a la
vista
significa que debemos mantener un 10% de
esto en las reservas y podemos prestar
el resto de las reservas y ahora puedo
agrupar mis reservas en lugar de decir
un millón de pesos de reservas totales
podría sub clasificarlas como reservas
requeridas reservas requeridas y
reservas en exceso
ahora cuáles piensan que serán las
reservas requeridas y en exceso en este
escenario pausa en el vídeo y traten de
resolverlo bueno las reservas requeridas
y las reservas en exceso van a sumar un
total de 1 millón de pesos
las reservas requeridas son el 10 por
ciento de los depósitos a la vista
entonces tengo que mantener el 10% de
este millón de pesos lo que es igual a
100 mil pesos y el resto van a hacer
reservas en exceso por 900 mil pesos así
que este modelo se basa en la idea de
que estos depósitos a la vista provienen
de muchas personas diferentes y es
estadísticamente poco probable que se
retire más del 10% en cualquier momento
y hablamos de bancos donde algunas veces
esto tiende a descomponerse y entonces
los bancos prestaran este otro 90% de
los depósitos a la vista o hasta el 90%
de los depósitos a la vista y los
prestarán a personas que creen que
probablemente paguen el dinero con
intereses
y ese interés es la manera en que los
bancos hacen dinero
entonces este banco podría decir oigan
tengo 900 mil pesos de reservas en
exceso que puedo usar para hacer
préstamos a otras personas así que
digamos que viene mucha gente que tiene
buenas ideas y pensamos que nos van a
pagar de modo que lo que hacemos es
tomar estas reservas en exceso hasta 900
mil pesos y en lugar de tenerlas como
reservas en exceso podemos ponerlas como
préstamos entonces podemos hacer
préstamos por 900 mil pesos ahora una
cosa que podría ser contradictoria para
algunos de ustedes y podrían decir
espera estoy acostumbrado a que un
préstamo es algo así como un pasivo aquí
dijimos que le debíamos dinero a la
gente y que eso era una obligación para
otras personas porque es un activo aquí
bueno depende si eres un prestamista o
eres la persona que toma prestado el
dinero aquí como banco somos el
prestamista el préstamo es un activo
porque alguien nos va a devolver dinero
en el futuro
esto tiene valor si tomamos prestado
dinero de alguien más entonces eso sería
un pasivo y ahora fíjense que todo el
tiempo que estuvimos haciendo esto los
activos fueron iguales a los pasivos más
el capital los activos ahora son dos
millones de pesos un millón más cien mil
más 900 mil y nuestros pasivos más
capital son dos millones de pesos un
millón en pasivos un millón en capital
hasta el próximo vídeo